I don't really care what
anyone thinks I should be doing.
All I want to do is wrestle.
When I first started
with the Monster Factory,
I said to myself like if I
got one person to the
WWE I'll be happy.
Danny Cage,
you have this school,
the Monster Factory.
He teaches you everything;
how to do the cameras,
be a referee,
build a ring.
Whenever we're doing
something in here,
you do it a hundred percent.
I was working in one
of these dead end jobs.
As soon as I walked in,
I was like...
this is awesome.
The rush of being
in a wrestling ring
is like nothing else.
Professional wrestling is,
an eclectic melting
pot of misfits.
I mean I'm from Philly.
So, an underdog
is a hungry dog.
Part of me didn't want to
call myself Twitch.
But how many
wrestlers do you know
not only have Tourette's
but are like open about it.
Professional
wrestling is a very
hard industry to make it in.
The odds are against you.
I mean there's
thousands of wrestlers,
everyday just trying
to get tryouts.
But I've gotten
more people there
than any other
coach in the world.
I could either walk
out as champion
or I could go back
to flipping burgers.
We have forty students.
They still have to get signed.
They still have to get better.
Let's go.
♪♪
My body isn't what
it used to be.
I saw this
goddess crumble.
You are good.
Right now you're not.
It's just been an off night.
There's a lot of
stuff happening.
I tried to quit and
Dan didn't let me.
I have just constant fear.
Path to paradise
begins in hell
and if you're going
through hell,
keep going.
Go!
♪♪
Oh God!
She got invited
for a WWE tryout.
♪♪
Wrestle for the WWE?
Hell, that's the dream.
Make sure they don't
kill each other.
Or if they do just clean up.
♪♪